(roaring)
- [Narrator] The newest
Jurassic World installment
is upon us like a hungry T-Rex,
who doesn't have any
feathers for some reason.
Here's a few things Hollywood
is still getting wrong about dinosaurs.
(dramatic music)
Many dinosaurs had feathers.
But the dinosaurs of Jurassic World
are covered in scales like
crocodiles and lizards.
They might have made an effort to stick in
a few feathers on this dinosaur,
but even if they did,
that's not a real animal;
it's a hybrid of two different species,
which brings us to our next point.
Genetics doesn't work that way.
- What is that thing?
- They made it.
- [Announcer] This is the
most dangerous creature
that ever walked the Earth.
(growling)
- [Narrator] Sure, some species can breed.
That's how you get a liger.
But the Indoraptor isn't like a liger.
It's a mix of a type of
tyrannosaur and raptor,
two very different kinds of animals.
It would be more like
if you tried to breed
a lion with a wolf instead.
It's just not going to happen.
The DNA isn't compatible.
(roaring)
Dinosaurs didn't roar.
In the first Jurassic World, T-Rex's roar
was made from a mix of animal sounds,
and it sounds pretty
similar in the new film.
But dinosaurs didn't roar like a lion.
They're related to birds,
which means their voice box
was probably similar to a bird's.
Raptors had wings.
First of all, raptor hands
didn't droop down like that.
In reality, that would only happen
if their wrists were broken.
In truth, raptors, like
birds today, had wings.
They couldn't fly, but the wing shape
means their arms look nothing like this.
Dinosaurs were colorful.
Yeah, Jurassic World's
dinosaurs are way too dull.
Sure, earth tones like green and brown
are common in today's reptiles,
but paleontologists have found
that dinosaurs came in a
kaleidoscope of bright colors,
just like today's birds.
Some even had shiny, iridescent feathers.
We get it, Hollywood.
T-Rex is scarier with its iconic roar.
(roaring)
And velociraptors looked more vicious
without those ridiculous feathers.
But come on!
You could at least add
a little more color!
(sighs) Maybe next time.
- It was all a lie!
- [Narrator] This video
was made in large part
thanks to paleontologist Steve Brusatte,
author of The Rise and
Fall of the Dinosaurs.